l'ex pdg d'air canada câlin rovinescu et
l'entrepreneur mitch garber investissent
dans john erreur mobility une entreprise
du texas ayant des services de
fabrication à montréal l'entreprise
développe notamment un projet
d'hélicoptère de taxi aérien électrique
avec nous pour en parler l'entrepreneur
et investisseurs mitch garber bonsoir
bonsoir et merci qu'est ce qui a attisé
et attirer votre intérêt dans ce projet
en particulier mais qui carbure
mais c'est simplement que ma
connaissance
aéronautique parce que j'en ai pas d
expertise mais une compagnie qui veut
bâtir au québec à quelque chose qui est
vraiment le futur c'est à dire que je
pense qu'on va tous à utiliser la
transplantation est les trucs dans le
futur on utilise mais pense certainement
la voiture mais les avions les hélicos
les taxis à le fait que le québec et le
canada sont vraiment des leaders
aujourd'hui devient des rideaux dans le
dans les batteries électriques dans le
transport électrique dans l'énergie
nette le participation de kaehlin qui
est un expert en aéronautique a expliqué
jeudi à l'ats que vous l'avez dit donc
c'est vraiment la cote et futur climat
québec qui m'arrivait est ce que ces
hélicoptères ce type d'hélicoptère puis
on parle d'une entreprise du texas ici
vole déjà
non il va prendre le premier vol d'essai
en 2023 et font probablement le premier
vol commercial en 2026 ça c'est le plan
et les premiers vols chez nous au québec
ce serait qu'un
2023 pour les essais au cas pour la
certification et tous et 2026 pourra
pour les deux transportation des clients
est-ce que vous investissez dans sa avec
l'espoir que ça marche ou vous avez la
conviction que la technologie est à
point pour créer ce type d'appareil
c'est les deux c'est sûr que ceux qui
gèrent la compagnie un québécois a
récolté à un certain martin fabia 1 qui
vient de bell helicopter pilot de
bombardier avec toute leur équipe qui on
l'espère sion les dessins et lyon sont
les ingénieurs donc ils peuvent le faire
c'est sur cette course il ya beaucoup de
compagnies partout dans le monde qui
essaie de le faire il ya un chose certes
ingérable en dix ans en quinze ans en
vingt ans tous les modes de transport
vont être électrique donc pourquoi pas
ici au québec donc c'est les deux c'est
un peu un gage et la confiance à qui
sont destinés ces appareils
mais ils sont noirs c'est à paris
probablement ils vont coûter entre 1 et
1.5 millions de dollars à un transport
disons de dorval au centre ville ça peut
coûter 40 dollars dont ce n'est pas
destiné aux riches c'est destiné aux
mêmes personnes qui prend ouvert qui
prend des taxis ça peut être même moins
cher que new bell il va vraiment ce que
l'électrique c'est pas cher oui vraiment
donc c'est pas c'est pas une menace pas
une mode élite de tout donc on pourrait
faire comme vous dites on part de dorval
on s'en va au centre ville on fait des
courtes distances un peu de temps à prix
abordable avec ce type d'appareil la wii
et avec la technologie de 2022 ça va ça
va de sa va pouvoir faire 200 kilomètres
donc avec les technologies de 2026 qui
s'est probablement beaucoup beaucoup
plus loin s'en charger les batteries
mais c'est la réalité ce qu'on voit
maintenant à sur l'écran c'est la
réalité ça va exister
on va tous se transporter avec des
appareils comme comme celle là c'est sûr
donc ça c'est pas une menace pas
légitime ok mais pourquoi john investis
au québec pourquoi choisi le québec pour
fabriquer ces appareils
mais je sais pas si vous le savez mais
le canada c'est le seul pays au monde où
on peut fabriquer une batterie
électrique de haut a à z sans aucune
aucune âme pièce morceau minérale
d'ailleurs donc l'expertisé gros spatial
et aéronautique ou québec on à
bombardier cae pratt whitney a bel ali
kopter bombardier donc on est dans le
centre du monde aéronautique et on est
avec les batteries électriques et la
technologie ont de vrais internat centre
de transport électrique
vous êtes je me permets de questions
supplémentaires qui ne porte pas sur les
taxis aérien aujourd'hui mais dit garber
vous êtes un investisseur quand même
prolifique entrepreneur vous avez
investi dans le kraken de siat au ouaki
la première saison s'achève là dans
quelques semaines est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de cette première saison
mais il ya deux côtés il ya l'eau les
habits à côté raki pile côté affaires en
affaires on est parmi eux
parmi les premiers en revenu brut est
revenu net dans le livre donc pour ça on
est très content
côté appui des partys est super content
à écouter sur la glace on aurait espéré
un meilleur affichage
lots maintenant on tourne envers les
agents libres et le période échanges
après et le repêchage qui va se faire
ici à montréal de 7 et 8 juillet donc
oui je suis très satisfait mais toujours
toujours de marge d'amélioration
vous aimez cette expérience
d'actionnaire d'une équipe de hockey je
peux pas aimer plus c'est possible et
est ce que vous êtes toujours engagés
dans le retour du baseball à montréal
mais honnêtement quand civile a dit que
c'est mort on est on va pas fait on
appelle une erreur mais pour l'instant
c'est mort ça veut pas dire que ça peut
pour renaître mais c'est vraiment c'est
une histoire un peu triste peu dommage
mais si on peut toujours espérer mais
honnêtement c'est vraiment un peu
probable ça prendrait un miracle
mais là c'était trop m mais vous parlez
de mort et de ressusciter alors on n'est
pas loin
on n'approche pas qu'on peut dire ça
mais dieu merci beaucoup toujours
plaisir